oh what's up everybody this is titan
titans of cnc
and i'm here with my son tyson hey
what's up ah
so welcome to the boom bastic show here
at titans of cnc
it's going to be an incredible week we
got every single day monday through
friday we're gonna have four episodes
four live episodes
we're gonna give you live machining
demonstrations we're gonna talk about
incredible technology we're gonna bring
in incredible
industry for for professionals to come
in and actually speak about the
technology
and how to use it when to use it you
know application specific
and all that and it's going to be an
incredible journey
so so and one of the greatest things
is we are live so i can't mess up we're
just gonna have some fun
and uh it's gonna be amazing so uh
as far as the machining goes uh put my
son tyson on the spot
what's up tyson got a pretty cool part
we're gonna be running up yeah yeah
excited yeah you know at the end of the
day we just like need to come in and we
just got to be
real right we've had the virus we've had
a lot of things happening in our
economy a lot of people have suffered
we've been locked down
and uh you know the big conventions
aren't happening you know so
we actually went to our amazing
partners and said hey you know since the
conventions aren't happening let's just
do something dynamic let's do something
fresh like
something boombastic right and actually
do the machining and do and give
incredible
discounts so through the whole process
you're gonna see
discounts coming down below us we have a
landing page
titansofcnc.com promo and uh it's going
to specify
the incredible deals deals like doosan
is giving 25 to
30 percent off not their
garbage machines they don't have any
garbage machines but their best machines
the machines that everybody are
purchasing 25 to 30 percent off
we got discounts from shunk and
kennametal huge discounts from canna
metal
blaser all of our partners and it's
going to be an amazing journey
and uh to start it off uh on this
particular session
we're going to actually machine a
titanium part
on this machine now tyson
cool story with tyson is tyson started
working about 18 years old with me yeah
we're doing a lot of aerospace work
and he actually worked with a great
journeyman machinist that did all the
programming so
for five years he set up every single
job
for these complicated parts and then one
day
the journeyman machinist left and we had
a huge amount of aerospace parts that
needed to be done within
weeks and i basically went to my son i
said hey we're going to actually throw
you on mastercam
we're going to actually teach you how to
do it i'm busy with my own parts but
you're just going to have to run
and from that day forward he actually
dug in he learned the software he made
incredible parts
and over the next 10 years has just been
such an amazing uh
you know my son but just such an amazing
employee
leader in the company and a guru right
when it comes to the lathe work uh one
of the exciting things is that
you know life is levels and machining is
levels so he's actually gone from
running
regular lathes and big lays to running
live tooling like the puma 2600 over
here
and actually bringing in some milling
and stuff and and
i always kind of pushed him towards the
lathe because i was more of a
mill guy right but now he's
like joking with me the other day and
he's like hey dad since i'm a
male guy on the mill turn and a late guy
i should get paid like twice as much and
stuff and i'm like
yeah i don't know about that but like
you definitely deserve something because
you're solving my problems and stuff so
today we're just going to be like really
really you know just candid about
you know what it takes to actually run a
machine like this to
wrap your head around a machine like
this
i always tell people whether it be
aluminum titanium inconel
there is a tool for the application
there is a machine for the application
the trick
is to figure out efficiently what those
tools
are and what that process is so you can
actually run and be successful
and make money in this industry so
nice you want to talk a little bit about
like like how
different is this machine from the other
machines that you use
the length portion's pretty similar but
then it it's basically a mill with the
upper like the upper turret you got like
80 tools
yeah 80 mil tools yeah 80 80 ml tools
it's basically treating both of these
two turrets separately so you load two
programs in at once
you have to prove out two programs
it's it sounds a lot but then if you
you know break it up between the two
like if you focus only on one when
you're setting up
yeah it's a lot easier yeah i i tell
people a lot of like a programmer cnc
programmer
just needs to be cool under pressure we
need to look at a complicated part we
need to dissect it
and we just need to go step by step and
actually
just prioritize based on where it is
in the process and uh if you do that and
yeah you're cool with it you're just
going to make it happen
and you know the mil stuff a lot of it's
new to me
but i have the best help in the world
when it comes to it oh
man oh man i was like finally stepping
into the mill so we get to like talk
about these like
you know harvey cutters for the titanium
from canon metal and
the speeds and feeds the surface foot
the depths are cut and
having some fun even last night we were
here late getting ready for this and
it's been an amazing journey and uh
just now just now like this is real
we're machining 604v titanium so
the the part actually came like chronic
crooked right because it does that's
what happens in the real world and you
have to solve problems so
he told me minutes before with the
camera he's like hey i should
actually face one side flip it just so i
can get a nice
bite on this thing of course we got the
shunk chuck
which like digs into it but we don't
want this thing rocking too much right
and just in that you were talking about
like the g54
what are the three things that you were
just telling me you have to change
oh so you have a g54 for both the lower
and the upper turret so something like
this where you're moving in the part
you need to remember to move both of
those g54s in otherwise one's going to
be off and
possibly crash and then also because i'm
doing a chuck transfer
i had a g54 set to the front of my jaws
so i also have to make sure to move that
in the same amount yeah that's that's
one of the cool things is we're actually
starting on this truck right here
and then we're going to machine it we're
going to mill it and then we're going to
do a
chuck transfer into the second chuck
and actually finish it off and that's
the whole thing with mill turns
is you want to come out with a complete
part and with that
i figured you know what let's actually
bring in our man chris from ellison
to actually come and speak to this
machine the technology what's up chris
hey ty how's it going
man how's it going awesome so our fans
right out here
uh hey guys students machinists from all
over the world and stuff uh this is
chris
and he is a amazing soldier earth type
of guy
and all that and uh we're happy to have
him so chris thanks a lot time oh of
course man
so yeah i gave you the good intro man i
know i appreciate it man i appreciate it
thank you
we um when looking at a mill turn
correct
when looking at a mill turn um what are
some of the things that
why do people actually purchase these
machines so
again what you're doing like your talk
like you're talking about is you've got
you've got the mill and you've got the
lathe and it's combined you're hitting
it all in one set up so this machine
we're looking at
and you've seen that you've talked about
it it's nine axes
so let's talk about that just for a
second so in the head how about
we move back let's do and then go ahead
and just start
looking at the camera explain the axis
of movement go ahead and try so you can
perfect so if we got in the head up here
we've got
the z-axis we've got x coming up and
down and we've got
y coming in and out across the part
that's your that's your milling head
that's like your three-axis mill then we
have a b
axis going back and forth like this so
you can hit those angles on either side
so that's four axes
up in the head then we've got our lower
turret this is like just a two axis
lathe with live tooling on there so
we've got the z-axis
and then we've got the x-axis like you
would have on a puma lathe
with the bolt-on live tools regular
regular turning tools
and then we've got the a-axis which is
actually that sub-spindle
moving in and out to help you grab those
longer or shorter parts if you want to
do use both to turn the part
and then you've got the c-axis one which
is then becomes your fifth axis
if you're using it in conjunction with
up here you've got four plus one you've
got a five axis mill
on the main and then on the sub you've
got another c-axis we've got a five-axis
mill
on the sub as well so you've got turning
you've got three axis milling and you've
got two five axis setups within one
machine
awesome a couple couple things to
mention is like this
this spindle on the mill is a beast and
like what's the horsepower maybe
this is a 35 horsepower it's going to
jump over this side
this is a 35 horsepower 12 000 rpm
spindle so
it's it's not like your late tools on
you on your lathe with live tooling
you know maybe it's maybe it's five
seven thousand rpm
10 horsepower or so this is a 35
horsepower 12 000 rpm
true milling spindle so talking about
your your
your monels your titaniums your
inconel's you can get after it with it
this is a true
true milling spindle and then with it i
heard you guys talking about it you've
got
80 tool magazine tool changing so again
with uh with a live tooling lathe
each one of these becomes an attachment
that you're going to be taking on and
off right
if you've got a part and you've got to
drill it you've got to tap it maybe
you've got to ream some holes you've got
some angled holes
you very quickly run out of uh of these
spaces right
and these these units they're not
inexpensive units right and you have to
service them
whereas tool changing mill you've got 80
tools you say hey i need to do a 37.5
degree angle
programming it and boom and it goes
right yeah yeah yeah exactly
not not boom like you're crashing the
machine but no no no no no
we're solving problems making it happen
like oh
yeah he was talking about the tools and
stuff magazines you got 40 tools in this
magazine
you got 40 tools in this one and uh and
it's great
another thing that i'll mention is that
this is a
a nice part titanium 604b
but we can actually put some beast parts
i think we're about like a couple feet
diameter and
five feet long in this particular
machine right correct yeah two about two
feet
wide five feet long hold it over the
whole width of the machine
machine that whole piece but you've got
to remember as well
steady rest but you've got to remember
that there's smaller ones of these and
there's bigger ones of these
and this is again there's so much
flexibility with this platform of
machining
it just combines so much reduce all that
setup takes out all that waste that's
what that's what you're looking for
right absolutely so
so who is the customers that actually
look at that looks at this
this technology you're talking big
aerospace companies anybody that
actually have like
you know big valves and different pieces
where they just want to like
best basically press go and have a
complete part come out
and then put more material in and just
complete non-stop
yeah exactly and it's but to your point
though it's not
it's not just the huge aerospace
companies of the world it's not just the
boeings and the air buses
it's hey if you've even if you've got a
job shop and you're finding that hey i'm
taking parts from the lathe i'm putting
them over to the mill
i'm how you know i'm changing out these
live tool holders on my on my turning
machine
if you're just making tubes with with
flats around them and holes and maybe
some some
some profile cuts this machine takes all
that setup all that label that waste out
of it
and ultimately it makes you more
profitable absolutely and
you're thinking about it like as a
machine shop owner you know i'm always
thinking about time is
money right and we want to run the
machines long
so we want to look at automation and
later on we're going to talk about
robots and programming robots and
and how to like move the shunk chucks
and get everything to work
automated and in the same way this is a
machine that
you program it you get it all set up and
then it
runs and you walk away from it and you
can run
a different machine and uh just true
efficiency
and once you get the thing dialed it's
just dialed and perfected
it's running keeps keeps running keeps
running absolutely so
i think uh we now we talked about the
machine
thank you brother boom now
one thing i'm going to do you know i
want to bring in michael from shunk
what's up michael hey titan my boy right
here
so so mike is with shunk and we actually
work a lot together like i'll need like
problem solved and i'll just text him
i'll call him at all hours of the night
especially since i'm pacific and he's
on the east coast but uh he always
answers the call and then i'll just
facetime and i'll be like hey what about
this what about that and he always comes
with a solution
and it's awesome yeah yeah and we were
here last night and we were just talking
about it
you can have a machine you know an
amazing piece of equipment that you
bring into your facility
and uh and it's and it's amazing right
but we have to think about all the
different variables
so when it comes to the different
variables we have to think about okay
you bought an amazing machine
but what's the chuck like what's the
pressure
how do the teeth dig in like what's the
rigidity
like so you have to have great work
holding to have a success in a machine
like this and that's why every time we
bring in
an actual great technology we bring in
the work
holding to couple it for success
so mike maybe you can uh talk a little
bit about the chucks
why they're different uh i can clearly
see some different sense
we'll just talk to the camera and point
that point everything out
yeah sounds good yeah thanks for having
me of course man thank you
so um yeah just like you said um
the machine is a big investment and we
want to make sure that when you're
making a big investment like this
the work holding has got to match and
the work holding is critical
so with a big investment you want to
make sure that investment stays running
so what we put on here this first chuck
on the main spindle is our thw
plus chuck uh and this thw plus it's a
quick jaw change chuck
okay and so the reason for that the
reason that came about is um
you know they've been around for a
little while but now they're becoming
more and more popular
um especially because people are wanting
to do lower part run sizes i mean that's
the same thing you guys are seeing here
especially when you say quick change
some people might not
know exactly what that is can you
explain the process and the time that
you
save on every operation yeah for sure so
basically what it is is normally when
you're changing the jaws on a chuck
you're having to unscrew the bolts and
take the jaws off of the master jaw and
if they're bored jaws for example you're
going to need to reindicate
where where those jaws are or maybe even
um return them re-board the jaws exactly
all right
so the idea with this chuck is you know
for example we've got claw jaws on there
right now
for the first operation to really bite
into the material
and one common way a lot of people use a
chuck like this is they've got claw jaws
for the
clamping on the raw material and then
they just
can quick change that and i'll explain
that in just a second and go to uh some
soft
board jaws and the nice thing is is
because you're not
the way the quick change works is we've
actually got a little um
wrench right here that you can just
stick the allen wrench in there turn it
a quarter turn or so
slide the jaw out and once you've done
that you can slide the new jaw back in
there's also a safety mechanism to
prevent you from being able to take the
wrench out when there's no jaw in there
that's nice that's nice and it also has
to
engage with the new jaw um before you
can take the wrench out as well
so until that engagement takes place you
can't take the jaw out or
sorry you can't uh yeah take the wrench
out you're thinking so every single time
you set up a new job
you go from like you know 10 to 30
minutes depending
down to like four minutes exactly yeah
so you're talking really good cost
savings there
um and that you know that's not even
accounting for needing to re-bore the
jaws and stuff like that
but yeah exactly like you just said yeah
one of the things that i'll point out
is that you know he was talking about
the teeth they joke around a lot of
shops call it the
vampire jaw because they it just digs
right into the material
so this is titanium it's a hard material
but uh
it was important for us to dig into that
material as you can see we have a
mill that's going to mill all across the
top of the material
and there's nothing down here right it's
not big enough for us to use a steady
rest
so there's nothing down here so we
wanted to
bite into it over here to just force
that rigidity so we can still
get over here and actually do a lot of
good machining
and uh yeah amazing engineering amazing
uh
job and uh thanks brother for the
support man yeah of course
so you guys ready to see some cnc
machining and then as we're machining
we'll just go ahead and kind of walk
through the process and uh nice
before and one thing is like when we
finish with this we're going to actually
take the videos
and we're going to put them on our
aerospace academy
again this is great technology we'll
probably put it on our regular academy
and aerospace academy
it's great for general engineering it's
great for aerospace
and we're going to put up the tool list
so you can actually click on each tool
from canon metal
and actually see exactly what we
actually uh used to program it
i wanted to mention kena metal kenmon
has an amazing end mill the end mills
that we're using
they have an amazing program right now
for the harvey
the harvey iii the harvey one te and the
core
five instead of the and they've dropped
the price
starting at 41 for some of the best end
mills in the history of the world like
they're amazing
you guys again you can watch our
aerospace academy to see us using those
end mills
efficiently in titanium in monel
in steel and aluminum and all of it
and uh with that uh tyson maybe talk a
little bit about the application how
we're going to start out
yeah so um
we're going to be switching between
lathops and mill ops
we're going to start by turning the part
roughing it out
then we're going to have the shell mill
or the face mill come in
we're going to put a big hex around the
part
after that we're going to run the finish
off again with the lower turret
and each time the upper and lower turret
they're just going to be taking turns so
lower turret's going to come in do some
lathe work where it's done it's going to
come back
melter it's going to come down do some
mill work
so yeah
then we'll we have um these group these
slots
going around the part kind of at a
spiral it's kind of a cool
little then it turns into a five axis so
it's going to be doing some five
axis work so i have a full nose end mill
um a harvey one coming in it's gonna
rough out those slots
and then i have a harvey three ball mill
coming in to um
do some ball tracking and finish up
those slots
awesome awesome you know you know what's
fun is that uh
like you know we're on camera right so i
could we could have just started with an
aluminum part or something else but i'm
like i'm like tyson
i'm gonna have you step right into that
machine your first program is gonna be
titanium because people are gonna call
us out if we're not running something
legit
and then we're going to do it live so if
you break a tool
if the park comes out if anything
happens you're going to be live in front
of the world just a little bit of
pressure just a little bit of pressure
right but like i told you i said we're
going to come in
we're going to have a great week and uh
at the end of it we're going to look
back at a body of work and it's going to
be an amazing thing and we did a huge uh
service to the industry it's kind of
great love you
you're going to do great now all the
pressure's on him so i'll let uh
tyson kind of take it away and then
we'll just kind of speak to the
application and
uh yeah and chris maybe if you want to
come back we can just kind of talk as
it's machining
cameras will go into inside the machine
to catch
everything uh do your thing buddy and
start it
yeah go ahead and start it take your
time take your time
oh that was nice he's high
yeah you're selling itself you move this
a lot so when you're
on this one you bring this over here and
then when it's time to machine knives
so i really like that
all right
you can go ahead and look at the camera
and go ahead and talk a little bit about
the kind of metal tooling that you're
using the
speeds in the feeds yeah so um
first up we have a cnmg doing some
roughing
it's gonna be facing the part leaving
five thousandths on the face
and then i'm gonna be turning across the
od also leaving five thousandths
um i believe i have this one at
160 sfm a feed rate of
eight thousands per revolution i think
cool
that's uh that's just a good middle of
the road
for 604b titanium uh to have success
live on camera but from there you can
actually push it up
yeah i think he actually took a skim cut
just to make sure that we were perfect
for the camera yeah so i've already run
this
first face pass just to make sure that i
didn't have to move it in anymore you
can hear the sfm kick
kicking up the rpm so it's going to be
turning across the od now
um i believe it was 80 000
should be 80 000 for the depth of cut
here
and then the first cut because of the
material kind of
not it has a little bit of run out on
the material it's
going to have like a uneven cut on this
very first cut but
after that it's going to be dialed
nicely i should be turning across about
uh two and a half inches maybe
maybe a little bit oh no i'm sorry uh
five inches that's quite a bit
awesome i guess this is one of the cool
things right when you go to the
big conventions you don't actually have
like legitimate cnc
machining right material is expensive a
lot of people are dry running aluminum
and different things but
um because we're in our facility live on
camera we can actually bring out legit
technology we can actually show real
machining like stuff that you can
actually see with your eyes
and therefore you can uh bank that
information what was that surface
what was that chip load what was that
tool that he actually was
using and then you can actually go and
duplicate that process because
it's real and you saw it with your own
eyes
boom see we got a nice nice short
chip coming off of there oh yeah yeah
looking beautiful
so ty's when you're when you're
machining titanium what are you looking
for
when you say you just said a nice short
chip yeah so
if you have your uh you want to dial in
your feed rate so that you don't have
too long of a chip to where
the chip would be wrapping around the
tool or the part yeah
you want it to break the chip very nice
like this to where
it's just out of the way and just coming
off nice
proud dad right now you know oh
and it's funny like two shop owners out
there you know when tyson started when
he was young i said it already i put him
on the lathe because i was on the mills
and i knew
i never had an idea that we would be on
camera i never had an idea we'd have
more than like
six employees it just wasn't even what i
thought neither right
it's been a journey it was through when
we went through 08 and 09
and uh at that time we had 55 employees
when we laid off 40 employees and i saw
the industry and i saw
like machine shops out there that were
running at 20 30
of their capabilities because nobody
talks to each other right and
and that's when i got an idea that hey
if we put a camera
on real applications machinists are
brilliant and
shop owners are brilliant and if they
just see it and they see the cut
then they can duplicate it and then they
can open their minds you know we machine
at a certain amount and we think the
machine's going to break if we double
that
well what happens if you quadruple that
or you go way
higher i understand that a lot of the
machines can do
so much more than what they've been put
to right because they want to be
successful and they've
they've set a standard and yet what we
want to do is we want to show amazing
things so
it can open people's eyes i always say
kind of like the matrix like we're going
to
expand your mind so when you see when
you're used to running at 100 inches a
minute
and you think it's fast because you used
to run at 30 we're going to show you
1600 inches a minute we're going to show
you 800 inches a minute and all of a
sudden you're going to be like wait
it didn't break what if i went to 200
what if i went to different things and
stuff so it's important to actually show
the application
on camera and uh besides our academy
it's just one way that we get it done
ah beautiful and chris you hear that
it's it's beautiful like it's just it
sounds nice it sounds real nice
we call it butter like it's cutting like
butter like huh it's a lot it's a better
job that you're programming and not me
but i i guess you know i was thinking
thinking a little bit about it earlier
and when you're saying why people buy it
right like
you you own a shop you ran a shop you
knew some of the headaches that people
had right and
and how much of the problems you have
moving stuff from lathes to mills back
to lathe
scrap and stuff changing the fixturing
involved is crazy
right exactly and that's the thing like
with a machine like this i mean you guys
are doing it your your
bar stock is your is your work holding
you're cutting it out of that
you've got your chuck if you want to
automate it you could put a bar feed on
the other end and throw
you keep throw work through the middle
of it have a parts catcher on this side
it's it's that done in one process you
know what we've been talking about
all the different ops and stuff all in
one
process and this is a cool part because
it actually has a lot of things going on
and then uh it's just gonna come out
done so
one of the cool things about today is
we're gonna actually have four live
events
and in those four live events we're
going to keep machining because this is
a part that's going to take a few
hours to get done and by the end of the
day we're going to see a completed
part and we're going to actually
probably put it up on the cmm
and actually talk about the inspection
and it's going to be great
again if you guys want to uh in a little
bit i'm going to have
my boy dave cox he's going to come in
here he's going to talk about how you
can take advantage of the amazing deals
from our partners we also have a website
that has links you can go travel around
and actually uh
check it out and see the incredible
things that are happening
you know doosan at 25 to 30 i mean is
that is an incredible they've never done
anything even
close to that and they're doing it for
you guys right now
and uh there's a lot of opportunities a
lot of people like you know we've been
through some adversity but with
adversity
comes a lot of companies saying how can
we actually bring this work back how can
we control the process
in-house how can we bring in mill turns
and live tooling and five axes
right and and now everybody's thinking
about it so
with the incredible deals we can make
that possible and then with our
partnership with ellison
with everybody else we're going to teach
you step-by-step
this this how to program how to
set up how to we programmed my mastercam
but we set up here
and how to set everything up and we're
going to go job after job after job
repetition after repetition all
materials
so that this isn't a mystery
it's like oh that's how i'm going to do
it it's going to be great
so i think i think it's a good time
right now we're just we're continuing to
face
we'll keep the machine running and at
this time i'm going to bring in my boy
dave cox dave what's up brother what's
up how are you
good so you this isn't a thing where i
actually just go
on camera and it's me i have an
incredible
team and and we look at videos we're a
manufacturing facility we're still
shipping content we're still inspecting
content
where we're taking the level of
expertise to the highest level i mean
look at this we're live
on facebook and it's a legitimate crazy
opportunity i know i get into it but i
just want to but with all that i just
want to tell you one of the guys that i
lean on
heavily is dave uh dave israel
is responsible for a lot of our graphics
and design and the look of everything
and
uh he's an amazing man and friend and
there you go
dave tell them about the deal i could
listen to them and go on forever but
let's get to some of these deals all
right so
you guys know that this boombastic event
is like it's legitimately insane people
haven't done this and it's coming to you
because other shows weren't happening
right like titan has said
the world is changing right now and so
we have to change with it and so we're
trying to do
bring you guys some killer deals i'm
excited because i got the best job in
the world i get to save you guys money
that's super fun right that's money in
itself so let's talk about these things
in line right so doosan machine tools
number one
like you said they're doing 25 to 30 off
that's not 25 to 30 off a small amount
so you're saving a couple hundred bucks
you're saving
20 80 000 on these things like that is
significant
so to get that deal 25 to 30 percent off
what you're gonna do is go to their site
right they made a landing page
specifically for this
and it's titans for doosan.com
that's going to give you all of the
terms and conditions going to give you
all the
insight that you need you're going to go
ahead and fill out the form there
they're going to help you get that
discount
and then when you go to the site you're
going to see the machines listed and
you're going to understand
how massive these savings are and like
you said again
these are not some machines that they
hadn't sold that they found in a
warehouse and they said oh crap
let's put a special on these these are
top of the line these are best sellers
and everything is in stock right now
ready to ship
so that's a huge deal the other thing
that doosan is doing
and i want to show you guys this let me
go back to that for one second
those deals again are just in select
markets right so this is north and south
america only
i'm so sorry everybody across the pond
other places
maybe eventually but right now it's
north and south america
the other really cool thing that doosan
is doing and if you guys on the cameras
can follow me over here
we're going to look at this gerstner
toolbox
tool chest you guys know about gerschner
you know about the quality of these
things
i mean gerstner is a company that's been
around for
114 years okay so
114 years in perspective that's when the
wright brothers were making their first
plane
like that's insane to have a company
around this long making tool chest
handmade beautiful craftsmanship in
dayton ohio
and these guys make these custom for
doosan and what doosan's doing
is for everybody who gets a machine
you're getting a free do
a free a free gerstner toolbox with that
purchase
okay this is for a limited time you have
to go through the website to get that
deal
titans for doosan.com the other thing is
we know
and we've worked with doosan and with
gerstner and we know that not everybody
can
pull the trigger on one of these bad
boys right away so we are actually
giving
this gerstner toolbox away during this
show
and what's gonna happen is you go again
to that website you go to
titansforduson.com
you fill out their form you're
automatically entered to win this
specific
gerstner toolbox cool stuff right
all right so now let's talk about canna
metal like titan said the kenmetal promo
right now
41 on select end mills that's harvey one
te
harvey three and the core five end mills
forty one dollars in the three eighths
inch size
fifty six dollars in the half inch size
okay
you're going to go to titansofcnc.com
promo
and you're gonna go ahead and click on
kenmetal and i'll take you right to that
landing page where you can find that
shunk is incredible so shunk is doing 20
off the vero s and contact packages
and the thw plus chuck so what you're
going to do is you're going to go to
their promo page that's titanscnc.com
promo and they're going to give you once
you fill out the form
they're going to give you that promo
code now titan
what you don't know is mike is
so hyped up he came off and he goes i
talked to my guys
we want everybody to be able to try the
impact series claw jaws and so what
we're going to do is add a promo
that we hadn't talked to you guys about
and this promo literally just came in
they want everybody to feel comfortable
trying those
uh claw jaws that they said that for 30
days you get them
for 30 days no conditions you don't like
them you send them back
they want you to feel comfortable using
them because they do grab
alright so that's what we got going on
there and that's it for promos you want
to tell them what's coming up next yeah
absolutely
awesome all right so as you guys can see
the machine thank you very much
dave so as you guys can see the
machine's still going
uh it's looking real good so uh
in about at 11 o'clock it's 9 38
right now at 11 o'clock we're gonna have
our next live event
and we're gonna see where the
application is at that time
where we're at in the machining and
we're gonna continue to
watch the process at the same time
we're going to actually talk a little
bit more about the machine we're going
to talk about the control
and we're actually going to talk about
mastercam
and we're going to show how mastercam
because of you know how we programmed it
it actually made
this part not easy but uh
because we're gonna teach you it it's
gonna make it easy for you guys all
right it's gonna be an incredible thing
also mastercam he probably already
mentioned that but
20 off their base products
that is huge one of the biggest
discounts in
mastercam has given and uh we're excited
that they're doing that for
our trade so if you thought about
getting mastercam get it
and at 11 o'clock uh next live event
talking about programming more machining
thank you so much for tuning
in to the bombastic show boom
hey what's up everybody welcome to
episode two
of our boom bastic show uh
tyson hey cutting some chips cutting
some chips so uh
you know during the break we had a break
of about you know an hour
20 minutes we actually uh turned it off
for a little bit
made some adjustments to the camera some
angles and i just started back
and now we're actually milling with a
nice
big what is a high fee cutter a 7792
high feed cutter uh
two inch two inch uh face mill yeah two
inch face mill
high feed from kanamel that's seven
seven nine
two and uh what's your surface foot and
chip load right now i got it at um
12 12 000 per uh tooth
okay and then um i think i'm going 200
about 200 sfm
200 sfm yeah yeah it's awesome you know
titanium right
every every material has an sfm
like allocated to it so if you're
actually looking like a machinist's
handbook a lot of times when you look at
604b titanium you'll see
you'll be at like you know 175 surface
foot so 200
is actually good um this this
high feed cutter can actually get after
it but we're being a little bit safe
because we're live on camera
and we just you know it's the first part
in titanium on this machine
and we just want to like make sure
everything's nice and smooth but i can
hear
just a little rumble right there so if i
gave a little bit more
feed i would like that little harmonic
you're hearing
i would actually get rid of that and uh
or tyson would get rid of that
and that's awesome one thing i'll say
about milling and titanium because if
you do
tricordial you know milling or
peripheral milling and you drop down and
use the side of the mill like the harvey
threes
we can get our surface foot up to 400
500 surface foot and you can actually
see a lot of those applications in our
aerospace academy
aerospaceacademy.com you know tys one
thing i want to
talk about when running titanium i mean
if you try like people see us running
titanium without cooling
right i mean they we run aluminum
without coolant because we can get away
with it
but you start milling with uh
titanium without coolant you're gonna
have a bundle of flames like against
fire
yeah fire it's gonna be crazy and stuff
so so what coolant are you actually
using
um i'm using the synergy seven seven
seven seven
thirty five seven thirty five yep live
on camera see that
so you know i mean that's a great thing
so
you know blaser calls it the liquid tool
and uh we actually use
735 in all of our machines um
small machines big machines never have
no issues whatsoever
and i love it because it's a synthetic
that's actually safe
for the machine which is not the normal
right
but it's safe for the machine and it's
clear
right so when i'm thinking about
education i'm thinking about filming
i want to have something that's that's
clear that allows me to see the work
piece when i'm actually
you know figuring it all out and the
students need to see what they're doing
but at the same time productivity is
real
and we got to keep it on a high level so
you know the clear coolant
that actually helps us machine titanium
more efficiently and that's the synergy
uh down below uh in there's promos on
the coolant for
everyone and uh it's an amazing thing
so right now right now what are you
doing you're doing a hex on the part yep
we've got a
big hex around the around the part um
just doing uh 25 25 000
passes um it's pretty
pretty wide hex so it hits it in uh
three passes
awesome awesome so you're taking some uh
taking the cuts we don't have anything
underneath it we're just holding it
with the chuck uh 25 thousands per
nice width and uh yeah making it happen
hey chris you wanna come on come in i
was just going to say it's done five of
them right now so
or it's working on the fifth one so okay
we're gonna do the sixth one pretty soon
it's kind of like working like a fourth
axis right now
so he he faced it and turned it and got
it all nice and now he's just taking
those flats boom flipping flipping
indexing making it happen sounds pretty
smooth
i love it yeah absolutely love it it's
great awesome great some real nice
programming you know one thing i was
i was i saw some video of a landing gear
like a big old landing gear and it was
awesome because
it was being ran on this machine yet a
steady rest it was an awkward size
like way out and you guys milled like
the customer whoever milled it did
everything was able to hold
it and um that was an awesome part is do
you see a lot of parts like that like
landing gears like
who what do they make on these machines
yeah so that's that's the thing with
you know with the machines like this
that they're flexible right so it's not
it's not just a lathe it's not just a
mill so you know a lot of people think
hey it's got to be tubes we've got to do
turning on this kind of stuff
but it's not necessarily just that to
your point yeah landing gears with odd
shapes maybe you got to come in and use
that you know use the true mill that
five
axis mill to profile out those shapes as
well as maybe you know come in with a
boring bar using that lower turret to
come in and do the id work on there as
well
so that's on the big side of things and
then also on the smaller machines i see
people doing
you know in the firearms industry we see
kind of the bolt carrier assemblies all
of that
on these smaller machines again you're
going to do that in one one setup one
shot one operation
and then everything in between the oil
gas big pumps
if you can hold it in that chuck and
again it doesn't have to be a three jaw
use a four jaw chuck a two jaw chuck a
collet nose
however you want to hold that raw stock
as long as you can swing it in that
diameter you can machine it because
you've got the flexibility of the
machine yeah that's awesome
right now we have two chucks in our
shung chuck that's on the other side it
actually has
six jaws and uh we use soft jaws
in that truck and one of the reasons we
have six jaws is we want to kind of
encompass the entire
part you don't want to like when you
have a thin wall part you don't want to
squeeze it on just a few places
because then where there's no jaw it'll
actually move
out right so we want to make sure that
we have contact around the entire
surface and that's when we
use the six jaw and uh yeah and it's
cool because a little bit later today
you guys are gonna see
a a transfer from chuck to chuck
and we're gonna machine the other side
do some threads do a
nice big drill you got a big drill
coming through there huh
inch and a quarter awesome awesome
thanks brother cool thanks a lot mate
appreciate it thank you
hey you know one thing i want to talk
about is uh
programming right because you know
programming
is huge we want it we want to make sure
that the green light stays green
that we program in mastercam we perfect
it we simulate it we we just look at
every little
variable when it comes to programming
and stuff and i thought it would be cool
to bring my boy
dylan out on dylan is actually a friend
of mine
he actually flew in for this event and
come on guys
he's like our problem solver so we solve
a lot of problems and
when we have problems that we can't
solve i'm just like same thing texting
them late at night whenever i'm like
hey what about this and what about that
you know and uh
i think it's important that we humble
ourselves too because
we're learning like tyson is learning
new technology and we don't know what we
don't know
and therefore instead of reinventing
wheel we want to like go straight to the
experts and dylan dude
you're just like you're on it all the
time man so oh
thank you very much for all your help
yeah it's a pleasure awesome
so mastercam yeah you got basic mill
you got basically you got five access
you got so many different things going
on you got mill turn
and stuff you know maybe can you explain
just a little bit uh to our audience
like what the maybe not quite what the
differences is but how
each one is just a different level you
have a foundation and you work up
let me talk a little bit about the mill
turn side sure
so we've got different software levels
targeted at
you know different machine groups
different processes and
you know specifically with miltern this
is its own beast right if we look at
this machine
you know you saw this this morning you
know we've got a multi-axis milling head
suspended in between two lathe spindles
with a lower turret with tools in both
directions on that
turret and then you've got lead tooling
in
the b head you know at different index
positions different angle orientations
so that kind of requires a different
solution
you know traditionally you've got you
know the software product the
programming and the post and they're
kind of stand alone
and a machine like this you you have to
combine those
you have to know what each component in
this machine is doing
at any one time and where it's located
so you've got to have full 3d simulation
and you've got to be able to control all
that motion at a programming level so
that's a really high end product that's
a
a different kind of solution than you
know traditional
five axis machining or just a
traditional lathe package
awesome and as uh tyson was saying like
it was crazy with the post but it kind
of like brought out like
two different programs that are all kind
of running at the same time and stuff
huh
yeah you have to um as far as the mill
turn goes you have to um
sync the two together so when you're
like in this case i've got this bottom
through doing some lathe stuff
you have to tell it after that lathe off
is done
to start you you link you link it to the
milling head so you tell it when this is
done start
start the mill head and then it'll wait
the program will wait for the mill head
to finish and then it'll start
you know your next lathe tool when it's
ready so just kind of
kind of timing the two together so that
they run
and stay out of each other's way you
know and one of the cool things too is
like in mastercam we actually put the
real chucks and we put the real machine
in you know we uh
we tool it up and uh therefore we can
check our clearances we can check
you know and watch the machining and
have a lot of confidence before we
actually come out
to the machine and stuff and i thought
they uh these guys can take you through
the journey
of how that works a little bit and show
you some of the tools coming up like
the the drilling and the thread milling
and all of that
i want to remind everybody you know one
of the greatest promos
ever like mastercam 20
off this week um not sure if they're
going to extend it but
you guys can actually go down to
titansofcnc.com
backslash promo go to mastercam
and you can actually check out this
incredible promo that they're running 20
off and uh amazing software then one of
the great things is because of our
partnership for education not just
education in schools
but in maschine like they talk about the
skills gap
right how do we solve the skills gap we
bring education
for free for everyone not just on small
machines
but on real machines that you actually
run in a real environment
to do high-end stuff so we're using
mastercam to teach
you know how to make all of these real
parts step-by-step
on the middle turn on the minx over here
on the
puma 2600 on the five axis that we're
gonna see tomorrow
on all of them we're just teaching the
trade so that employers can go out
they can actually go grab people off the
streets however if you've got a good
head on your shoulder you can put them
in
in-house training to solve that skills
gap
through our academy boom 20 off
i will uh thank you very much and maybe
you guys can actually go over here and
actually talk about the program and show
some simulation and stuff okay
sure
well so i got my i have my program here
off a side off b side
[Music]
you can see uh
got a lot of a lot of tool paths here
so we've got a little bit of everything
too you've got some multi-axis paths in
the uh
slot areas there and then a bunch of
indexing paths
all on the first side
so the pass we're doing right now is the
spacing operation
and then coming up pretty soon
um we're going to be going back to the
lathe off facing it
and uh doing a finish pass around there
and then we're going to start
jamming a little bit more in the mill
doing finishing
roughing and finishing all these slots
popping a uh
popping a drill in on all of the hexes
on all the heck
oh sorry we're going to be popping a uh
drill into all of the hex flats and then
thread milling them and when that's all
done we're going to do a chuck transfer
sending it back to the other chuck and
then we're going to do the back side
which is going to have threads on this
end and then we also have an id
bore a inch and a half id bore
on this side so
[Applause]
so here's the uh this is the post when
it
for the mill turn side um there's a lot
to go over i'm
not um but it's kind of cool because
like i mentioned
you have to link you know you have your
upper
upper turret here and you have your
lower turret here
and you have to link the two together
you link the two together so i told this
you know i've got my face pass
my od roughing pass on the first stop
and then when it's retracting
at the end of the roughing pass i told
it to sink it
to the facing mill that's starting right
now so the program is gonna wait
until this pass is all done before it
starts the face mill
and then i have another one over here
that's gonna wait
for the face mill to finish in order to
start
the next lathe pass so
you tie you time the two together
and then once you have these all timed
you can run the simulation
which i think i have to actually uh
click here
so once we've layered all the
intelligence of getting that
simultaneous motion with all these
different components
we launch right into the simulation
where we've got everything
modeled down to the sheet metal of the
enclosure so that we can see exactly
what the end result is going to be
before we go out to the machine
and that's really important on something
where you can't visualize this kind of
thing
as easily as you could in like a regular
five axis machine or a regular lathe
there's
too many moving components so you need
the software to be able to show you that
visually what is this machine going to
do how is the
turret going to move how is it going to
do this tool change
how is the head going apart
and see that all in real time i still
have to model a few things with my
with this program but modeling the tool
holders
and trying to get like my milling tool
like modeling
the holders that i was using on the
milling tools
i took a lot of measurements on those
tools and tried to get them as close as
i could
and it was a gigantic help trying to
make sure that
you know the side of like my uh
ball and mill it has a pretty long shank
on it making sure that shank's not going
to hit against the side of my material
that
the hex wall that i'm cutting right now
and then things like um making sure that
i have enough room
on the backside tools that i'm not gonna
hit
hit the other chuck you know
it really helps for those kinds of
clearances
so we got our machine our machine here
you can see i've got a couple of a
couple of my
tool holders on sorry
um you can see i've got my uh
my tool holders modeled here
those are the uh these are the km50 tool
holders
so i'm using those are the uh
km50 tool holders from canon metal i'm
using them on the lower turret
yeah i'll start the uh
slow it down a little bit start the
simulation here
you see i got the uh the first lathe
pass this guy
this upper turret's just chilling up
here then when it's done
it's gonna bring the shell mill and this
is that pass that's running right now
so in this case we've got plenty of
clearance to the chuck
the lower turrets out of the way and we
don't have to worry too much but when we
we start moving around all these
components together but you can see
you can also see like what i was talking
about here and what
he mentioned what dylan mentioned
you know trying to get your length of
your tool
as close as you can or if you can import
the model of the tool
it's very very important because you can
see when i
start getting um close to the uh
when i start getting close to this end
this turret gets pretty close to the uh
to the chuck and the jaws
so making sure that all of that making
sure all of that's dialed if it's
if you have your tool holders all dialed
in your in your program
you have less to worry about when you
when you actually run the part
yeah to take advantage of a simulation
like this you want to build your
component library out you know you've
got your standard tools and work holding
in your shop
so you're going to model all that up and
throw it in there and that pays
dividends
in your programming at this stage right
[Music]
here
speed this up a little bit
so now we have the lathe blade spindle
running again this time it's gonna
finish turn the part and then we start
with the uh
we have the end mill roughing out the uh
we have this end mill roughing out these
slots here
[Music]
yeah that's the harvey one te from kind
of metal
just taking two two passes
it does one
turns the turns the c-axis while
the milling head is uh turning across
[Music]
and then when that's done we're going to
run a
run a ball mill to finish it
[Music]
do some ball tracking
so
[Music]
so in here you're controlling the tilt
of the tool to the walls with your
c-axis orientation as well
so just kind of goes goes along the
walls steps down
um tries to get as close to the
center as it can over here we got our
lathe operation running right now
over here um it's finishing the face
right now just started
the shell mill finished so it's gonna
face it and then turn across the odd
kind of speed this up because this uh
there's a lot of these passes here
oh so here your tool
changing to the drill again uh now it's
gonna yeah
it's gonna start doing the uh the drills
for the hex
yep
so this is the whole hole for the thread
mill just gonna pop those in
and then we have a chamfer champer a
chamfer mill coming in
pops a 40 000 chamfer on those holes
and then we have our thread mill
awesome great job guys home master cam
uh i just want to remind everybody
master cam
20 off you can actually down below
you can go to titansofcnc.com backslash
promo you can actually go into mastercam
and see all of our other partners and
the promos that they're
all giving absolutely amazing
the industry the industry has suffered
and our partners are stepping up
to give huge discounts at a time where
we can't go to these big conventions and
stuff so uh
just just shout outs to all of our
partners and stuff another one of our
partners i want to do a special shout
out
is tms titanium these guys are amazing
you know when we were running a lot of
aerospace
parts and stuff they were a great
supplier
i gave them a vision that hey we're
going to step in and actually do
something big for education
for our schools for machine shops and
different things and they've come
along as a great partner to help lift up
that education you know
each piece of titanium i mean we're
talking thousands of dollars
on some of these pieces and uh yeah
again
great partner tms titanium if you guys
need titanium just go to their website
you can order it right through there
and uh todd on they're all they're all
amazing so
uh tms thank you very much and uh
with that uh i just wanna say uh i'm
gonna bring
in my boy dave one more time and i'll
let him talk a little bit more about the
promos do your thing brother hold on
brother
all right so promo time once again today
this time
we're going to talk about blaser okay
blaser swiss lube
what they're doing is unheard of it's 20
off all coolants cutting oils grinding
oils and edm oils with the initial fill
this is part of their lta package the
liquid tool analysis
so they do is they come in they do a
free liquid tool analysis they're going
to look at your
application the machine you're using
what your different specs are and
they're going to help you
dial that in to absolutely perfect
so that your tooling your liquid tooling
all works as planned
and they're giving you discount like
that's free and then you get discounts
on top of that
when you start to order that product
right so 20 off all the coolants cutting
oils etc
20 off cleaners and accessories they're
even talking about some mini mix jet mix
stuff in there so
definitely go and check out their deal
on their site that's blaser.com
slash boombastic that's how you get to
that blosser.combastic that should be on
your screen or it just was
next up let's talk about mastercam right
mastercam's incredible
these guys really stepped up and they
are un they're unlocking
everything for our community just so you
can see exactly how to use the program
we're teaching on that platform so 20
off on mastercam is no joke
and this is on all their core products
the mastercam educational suite and
those things include
lathe router design wire and the post so
you can actually post to your machine
so mastercam definitely check that one
out you're going to get that one by
going to titanscnc.com
promo next up is kennametal we mentioned
this on the last episode
but it's still here so the 41.38 end
mills
and the dollar half inch end mills on
all the harvey threes the harvey one tes
and the core five the beasts in these
different materials so definitely check
those out
um next oh one thing i want to mention
about that we haven't mentioned this yet
on canon metal that promo is so
incredible because what they did is they
actually teamed up with workshop for
warriors
and a dollar from every end mill is
going to that program workshop for
warriors
helps people get into that machining
trade right it's incredible
all of our veterans they need love they
fought for us
and so ken of metal is doing the right
thing they're given a dollar per end
mill that's bought
back to that workshop for warriors
program so definitely check that out on
the site
titanscnc.com promo
let's talk about shunk as well right so
shunk again that 20 off on their veros
contact packages and the plus chuck the
thw plus truck that we talked about
definitely check that out same link 20
off
you know about doosan you know about 25
to 30 off on all these machines
we talked about the free gerstner that's
going out if you buy a machine
if you want to just go ahead and go and
enter at their site titans
for doosan.com titans titansplural for
doosan.com that's how you're going to
get entered for that free gerstner
giveaway
and when you purchase something through
that link to one of the machines you're
going to
get a free gerstner and those things are
incredible i kind of i might steal the
one that we have here because i want
that for my house
let me talk to you also about tms
titanium and this is the last one
tms is an amazing partner like titan
mentioned helping us out with the
material
making sure that we have that in hand so
that we can show you
exactly how to run in these hard hard
titanium materials
so what tms has actually done is they
stepped up they're giving everybody who
orders through their site
a swag bag of all of their stuff so they
got face masks net gators
t-shirts stickers all that kind of stuff
so all you got to do is when you're
placing an order
at tms titanium at store.tmstitanium.com
use the code boombastic in the order
notes and they're going to get you that
swag bag
all right we hope you guys take taking
advantage of these offers we worked
really hard to get partners to
come to the table with this stuff and
really kind of stretch themselves
to give you this percentage off so
that's what i got titan
think you're up as far as what's coming
up next all right all right brother
so one thing you know we talk about all
the promos but i just want to have a
sincere moment right here
and i want to let everybody know you
know
we've never done something like this uh
five days
20 live feeds it's a huge huge uh
just a task but we were up for it
because our industry
needs it and and our and these deals are
great for the
industry it's great for you guys 25 to
30 percent off
on a machine as dave said is no joke
mastercam and all that
but i want you guys to understand that
although there might be a lot of sales
right we're not taking a cut i'm not
taking a cut
we we want the savings to go to you we
don't want to add anything to it so
we're simply the vessel that's bringing
the education
that's bringing the deals but we're not
taking a cut so please
you know if you're looking for a machine
if you're looking for a tool you'll be
looking look at
our partners look at these deals and uh
and understand that there's a lot of
companies out there but our partners
are heroes because they stepped up and
looked at manufacturing
and said hey we need to do something
about manufacturing we need to
excite our kids we need to bring
awareness we need to
like give new skills to the machinists
out there and show them
how to actually use high-level
technology
and therefore they came in community and
and partnership with us to help us give
free education
people thought we were going to charge
for education years back people are
saying oh he's
all of a sudden he's going to suck you
in and he's going to charge he's going
to charge
never has any teacher any machinist
been charged by us for education we do
everything for free because we
love this industry and we love you guys
coming up
in our next episode at one o'clock
pacific time
it's going to be awesome because we're
taking one of our
our stars here at titans of cnc jacob
sanchez
a kid a young man that actually started
right down the street at rocklin
high school using the academy to
actually learn cnc machining and we
hired them from that program
well jacob has now worked here for three
or four years
and he is in charge and and programmed
an amazing
you know just a simulation of automation
we're going to talk about like
how do you actually grab a part how do
you program the robot
like what kind of a vice do you use in
the fanuc
cnc machine the the robo drill what kind
of vice do you need from
shunk how do you program that vise
what type of jaws do you use what type
of jaws do you use
to actually put that material raw
material into that vise
you know and then how does the whole
relationship work so at one o'clock
we're just going to like it's just going
to be an awesome like down to earth
talk about automation how it's done
and we're going to learn a little bit
about fanuc and uh the robo drill
fanuc also has 20 percent off
the robo drill applications it's an
incredible
deal and again you can see it down at
titansofcnc.com
promo check it out all of our partners
thank you so much i will see you at one
o'clock
love you boom what's up everybody this
is titan with titans of cnc
and i'm here with mr jacob sanchez
what's up jacob what's up ty what's up
everybody
uh welcome to the bombastic event
episode number three and this is gonna
be a great episode because we are going
to talk about automation and we're gonna
show automation in process
and uh we're standing in front of a robo
drill
with a robot hook to it
and we're gonna actually do an entire
machine tending
demonstration and uh you know when i was
looking at
robots and machines it's like i couldn't
wrap my head around how
everything works because i wasn't i'd
never used a pneumatic vise i'd never
use
certain things and grippers and all that
but when i got it on my floor
and we started like working with it we
started looking at the grippers
and thinking like cnc machinists like
how would we actually make our
own fingers and we thought like hey just
like soft jaws
right and the same thing when it comes
to the vice inside the table
you know it was like hey how how should
we make this so a lot of the principles
we use
in cnc machining is the exact principles
we actually use
and uh jacob i mean you've come a long
way right
from starting off at rocklin high school
doing the building blocks and
getting you ready to go into the san
quinn prison system
i'd say i come a long way yeah people
are talking about the skills gap
and uh the academy in the high school
right down the street
this is where jacob learned making the
building blocks and then teaching the
teacher and
and teaching other students and stuff
and we hired him right out of high
school
and it's awesome right because like a
lot of the leaders at that school
they didn't think you had a future yeah
i wasn't one of the kids that was
planned on going to college right out of
high school i wasn't that
ab kid i was that ce kid sorry to
say that dad i know you're watching um
but i'm here now i've been here for
three and a half years and
working with the first robot cell we've
had in our shop
and it's going great absolutely and uh
you know somebody like
myself i'm a machine shop owner i need
to have confidence in my guys and uh
jacob is 21 years old and i got crazy
confidence in this young man
even from the start like he would be
coming on saturdays and he'd be like
hey tainan can you come to work on a
saturday and teach me some stuff hey
titan hey
talking to my son talking to tyson
talking to other people and stuff
but but you love that because you just
got after it and that is why
we actually put him in charge of
actually making our first
basic automation sell and then helping
explain it to you guys
and then we're going to make tutorials
to teach every little
aspect of it so you want to explain a
little bit about what's going to happen
today
yeah so what we're going to be doing
today is we're going to be picking
up a puck from our table situated to the
right of our machine
bringing it into our robo drill and we
actually have a pneumatic vise
which can open and close itself with
just a little
code so you don't have to go in there
and tighten it down the part
and that's one of the main things when
it comes to making an automation cell
you want it to do as much as you can by
itself
so getting a pneumatic vise is one of
the key factors to that
and once it's done with the part it's
going to go back into the machine
take it out it is going to place three
pucks
in the positions that i taught it and
it's gonna keep loading for three and i
have it stopped after it's done
oh yeah absolutely so you know we're
grabbing the material out then we're
cleaning the vise we're making sure
everything is like
absolutely precise today we're pulling
off of a table
because we actually have a a crazy
conveyor coming
that's actually going to bring material
to the robot and it's going to take
material away finished parts away from
the robot
so in a few weeks you guys will see that
hit our floor again
tutorials on all of it and then we're
going to go application after
application
for our new robot academy automation
academy so uh
you know all this work that's been done
over in overseas and different places
let's actually bring that work back
because of automation and now you got
people programming robots you know
making good money you got technicians
that are
that are you know just handling all of
that so
we're bringing back jobs we're creating
new jobs that are high
tech and uh we're bringing that work
back so boom
we running it yeah we're gonna run it in
a minute but first
um again earlier i was talking in
episode
number one we got some amazing
individuals here so
it is my honor to bring in paul he's
from fanuc
he's a director of education come on in
paul
hey jake hi titan how are you brother
good good jacob great job fist bumping
yeah excellent job awesome so so paul i
mean
one thing that stands out um besides the
machine and the technology
is fanuc itself how many schools
are you guys partnered with right now so
we have over
1300 schools across the country that
that have our products between robots c
and c
robodrill machines and really it's
testament to what jacob's been able to
do is
is students today need those experiences
they need to be able to
see and feel and touch this equipment to
understand what careers are out there
and he's doing just a phenomenal job
i've had the opportunity to talk to him
earlier today about this system and
how he's learning about the robot
integrating and loading
directly to the robo-drill machine yeah
you know you know what's funny is i
think that
the older generation we hold back our
kids
you know because because we can't wrap
our heads around certain things
but these kids grew up on cell phones
they grew up with automation
and problem solving and multitasking
they're always doing
20 things at a time so when you actually
let them go and actually put them in
front of the machine
it's amazing how fast they adapt and
just start figuring out things on their
own where you're like oh
that was all you figured that out like
it's absolutely amazing you know
that's just a word to the teachers like
let the students learn
and let them problem solve let them
advance and uh
it's a good thing they can do it and
they can they they're going to take our
entire
industry to a whole new level
when you look at 1300 schools that's 300
schools
that you guys talk to or they actually
have automation that's 300 schools that
have implemented
and have our automation in there
teaching students all around the country
our
our goal with our whole education
initiative is very much like yours
is really to get it in the students and
the real industry technology
put it in their hands let them
experience with let them understand how
this technology works
and as you mentioned this is a whole
generation of digital learners
they grew up not opening a book per se
to learn
they'll they'll learn it just by putting
it in their hands and trial and error
and and part of our technology is really
to make it more easy to use
easy simple integration between a robot
and a robo drill is
an ethernet cable between those two so
now you've simplified the whole
communication process
of making automation work with the uh
cnc machines like this
that's incredible another thing i i
promise
we promise this is episode three and
it's deals deals
deals right the industry has suffered we
don't have the big conventions
we have gone to our partners and asked
for the greatest
deals for our industry for our viewers
for our
students and uh spanish has definitely
delivered
a robo-drill packages can i say package
absolutely
right now 20 off
20 off these machines it's an incredible
deal
and they'll work with you based on the
application
based on like the industry that you're
going to serve because it's kind of
it's crazy right these things you can
just set them up for so many
different different processes oh yeah
extremely adaptable it's all about
speed precision and and performance we
really want to make sure that
we look at the application and then
configure this machine it's very
adaptable
so easy to use adaptable for a wide
range of products
so it's a it's a great package the
packages that we put together
range from just a basic machine all the
way through to a fully integrated robot
system
for loading and unloading with all of
the peripheral devices
included in those packages yeah it's
awesome and uh
you know with all those schools having
robots um with fanuc having their own
education
uh we are actually partnering together
so that we can actually create
additional curriculum to actually teach
all of these teachers all of these
students how to actually you know
let's start the machine let's actually
go through all the fundamentals
you know let's program let's do the
automation
and just make it very simple for them so
they they figure it out
and then they can just take it to
another level again if you want the
promo go down to
titansofcnc.com backslash
promo go look at fanuc while you're down
there
looking at fanuc look at all our other
industry partners like chunk and canna
metal
crazy kind of metal tools in there but
check them all out
every single partner has amazing deals
this week for the bombastic show and
with that
uh go ahead no i was just gonna say
one of the the key things is for uh
people like jacob is just understanding
how
everything works so his ability to get
into a school and learn this
this this is just it's really our
primary focus
in working with education but bringing
that closer to all the customers that
are out there
the knowledge that he has on how you
operate this machine
or really any cnc machine to configure
it to produce and machine this part
that he did that's really extremely
valuable knowledge
the first thing that we could have them
do is stand here all day and load and
unload that part
that's not value added what's value
added to a lot of these shops is
getting somebody like jacob that can
just manufacture and design this
part and then let the robot do the
loading and unloading and move on to the
next system
whether you're doing small batch or high
volume lights out
24 7 that's what you need absolutely and
it's important you know we just came
through you know
we haven't come through yet but you know
there's a virus right and there's a lot
of things that have like shut
us down and a lot of people have like
parks being done in other countries
where all of a sudden
they they that supply has stopped and
it's really
hurt their companies and stuff so we
have tremendous opportunities right now
and there are amazing companies
that are looking to actually bring that
work back to have control of that supply
in your own backyard and a lot of people
say hey robots fighting titan why are
you about robots they kill jobs and
stuff
and i'll actually challenge that and
i'll say you know what the job's already
left you already have 50
000 more than 50 000 companies leave
right
but now if they're using automation and
robots to actually make
an entire phone in another country why
can't we actually bring that automation
back
put it on our own floor automate it
and actually instead of having this this
many employees you're going to have this
many
employees but they're going to make good
money and
their employees they would have never
been in the workforce
because the work was already gone right
so this is how we bring it back
we have we have countless examples of
manufacturers that were losing business
overseas low-cost labor countries that
have added automation
increased their capabilities and now
they're producing parts not waiting on
those parts to come in and they're
actually exporting overseas to different
countries out there so
we're seeing it time and time again
manufacturing
is there's a resurgence in this country
and it really was
it kind of exposed some specific
industries during this
current covet crisis about how important
it is to manufacture here within the us
so we're starting to see a lot of
manufacturers continuously expanding
even over the last few months
that's awesome so paul can you take just
a take a minute
and maybe talk about some of the
features with this
robo drill what makes it spectacular
it's a phenomenal machine it's all about
speed precision and high power
so in here you've got 21 tool changers
a tool changer within that we can change
a tool in 0.7 seconds
and you can get from chip to chip in 1.2
seconds so
phenomenal speed from a horsepower point
of view this is really a performance
machine you've got a
24 000 rpm spindle on there
let's say we're tapping we want to do
rigid tapping within this
we can spool up that spindle in 0.16
seconds
to tap stop reverse back 1.6 seconds to
back that part out
just unbelievable you can tap it up to 8
000 rpms
per second so feed rates about 20 inches
per second on a feed rate on this
machine so very
high performance high precision uh
machine
it's made for working 24 7 around the
clock
a lot of the other features in here
traditional cnc screen but we have what
we call an
ihmi so it's more of an icon driven
screen so again trying to address some
of the digital learners that are
focusing on
how do i go to more an icon or a ease of
functioning and getting to certain
screens and then the other piece of this
is really creating ease of use is how do
we make this more
the operability the maintainability and
the automation ability within that
so i talked a little bit about that
earlier to connect the robot to the robo
drill
is as simple as an ethernet cable i o is
pre-configured
it already knows then that it's
connected to a robot and it's safe
and in this application where the robot
is loading and unloading
out of here we have a servo door so
rather than a pneumatic door there you
have to wait till the door is open get
that signal and then send the robot in
as that door is opening that robot can
be moving in as the robot's retrieving
the door is closing
again it's all about cycle time time all
those little
fractions of a second build up over
production
and the faster that we can keep this
machine cutting parts
those customers are making money that's
awesome thank you brother no problem
that's great
thank you i appreciate all you do of
course all right take care hey and uh
in our first episode today we actually
had mike
he's a good friend of mine and he's from
schunk and i'm going to invite him back
in because uh
we're using shunk grippers and we're
using a shunk pneumatic vice center
what's up brother hey back again boom
keeping you busy right
it's all good so you know a few things
that we'll talk about is like
as a cnc machine shop you know we have
to look at how we're going to
grab that material how we're going to
hold it the rigidity
get everything as jacob mentioned get
everything seamless
so you don't have to do anything it's
automated a hundred percent
and we do that with chunk products and
you guys are the leader
the leader in the industry yeah yeah at
every trade show i go to when i look at
the uh
the fanuc machines i see almost
every robot has a shunt gripper on it so
i'm proud to be a part of that company
and just kind of lead the industry in
that no known for the quality
yeah and again shunk down in our promo
section on our website
titansofcnc.com
promo shunk has some awesome promo
prices making it happen and uh oh yeah
yeah
how about we actually move around a
little bit and maybe you can talk a
little bit about the gripper
talk a little bit about the vise that
we're using and i'd love
jacob to maybe you can talk about like
how we actually went and designed our
own
uh tooling for the gripper 3d printed it
and actually
did it yeah of course it's always good
let's go ahead and talk about the
gripper itself
sure sure well um so i i actually
appreciated what you said earlier
um talking about kind of
you're used to working with workholding
yeah and then you come in and get this
new technology
well what's funny is this technology
here the technology inside of that
gripper
is the exact same as what's in that vise
so what it is is that it's core the
technology is really simple
inside that body is just a piston that's
moving vertically up and down
and when you want to open that gripper
you apply air to the open side
and when you want to close it you apply
air to the closed side
and that's it it's just a piston that's
moving vertically that's transitioning
this vertical movement
to a horizontal movement with the
fingers awesome and what's funny is the
tan device on that machine
that was actually our first gripper it
was it was actually a really heavy
gripper
but that tandem vice was the same
technology now is our first gripper that
we ever developed is one of our earliest
products
and so here you can see this is our pgn
plus gripper and essentially it's just a
two-finger gripper and you can design
your own jaws for it according to the
work piece
or you can purchase some kind of
standard generic jaws from us
and they're like i said it's air to open
and air to close there's two ports and
you just interface it to the end of the
robot you can see we
kind of have this angle bracket designed
on there to get that gripper and an
orientation that we'd like
um but essentially just run a couple air
lines to the gripper and that's how you
open and close the gripper
and just get it all programmed and
synced and and all good
you know when we got the robot where i
was i was looking at i was looking at
the fingers that come with it and every
single application is different
but all of a sudden i saw the simplicity
and like mike said
you know it just it opens and closes so
it's like oh let's actually like
think about rigidity let's make them as
low profile as possible and keep them
down close to the gripper and actually
and then let's actually machine
actually two diameters so uh
jacob went ahead and did that and
designed it and these are
the first set i'll let him explain it so
i worked with our
engineer billy i told him what my
process was gonna be i told him what i
wanted to make happen
we're taking a two inch raw stock which
is our
first diameter our outside diameter and
i told him i'm going to machine it and
when i finish i'm going to have a 1.9
so he also put another step
with a 1.9 diameter so you'll see
once we run the program and i go back in
to grab the puck
my robot will actually go deeper
because my robot will actually go deeper
because it needs to hit that 1.9 pocket
we made on the bottom
so it's a really nice process and then i
got to machine it
on the dnm 5700l and it was nice to get
that guy cutting too
awesome so we we tested out we actually
ran jobs
with the plastic and then once we knew
everything was perfect
went on with the aluminum and uh jacob
did the same thing over here
maybe we can uh can we move a camera
over here to look right inside here
so if we get this angle right here
curtis can you see that can you see my
hand
right here here boss i'll move it no
you're good
okay go ahead and explain the um
so we also started with 3d printing
these vise draws and once i knew that
the process worked with the pneumatic
vice actually closing in on my work
piece
i decided to machine it out of some
aluminum on the dnm
5700l and i wanted to keep that low
profile ball track surface you see on
the outside
because it still is it's a trunnion it's
a fifth axis i want to make sure that
i'll have clearances once i start
dropping tools
past those jaws so that was the purpose
of the ball track surface
great so all right i think i think
it's good that we can actually start
cutting some chips and go through the
whole
process so
a couple couple of unique things to talk
about would be
the sensors here you can see this light
right here as i
it's green that'll allow the robot to
move
fast a lot of times in the past we've
seen there's a cage
around a robot to protect humans but the
technology has actually come
way ahead where actually now you can
come right up
to the robot but as you get close
it'll turn yellow which will go to 10
percent movement
or it'll turn red which will stop the
robot
and it actually works very quick you
can't run into it it will stop
so jacob you want to talk a little bit
about what exactly the application is
what it's going to do and how you're
going to get it back yep sounds great
so the whole process that i wanted to
make happen with this part
is we didn't need it doing anything
crazing on the machining side
i wanted to get the robot and the
machine talking to each other which paul
said is
the beginning of your work cell so what
i did is i had
certain signals that let the robot know
when the
side servo doors open and i had the
machine
know when the robot was inside it maybe
grabbing the work piece because you
don't want anything
starting when the other isn't ready so
once i hit the green button it's gonna
pick up the puck
open the servo door put the puck inside
of our pneumatic vise
and it's all about little things like i
have little weight timers where it waits
0.5 seconds before it closes that
pneumatic vice
because the worst thing that could
happen is i'm going down to put my puck
and it grabs before i'm down
seated all the way or the opposite when
i'm trying to pick it up to bring it out
if it's letting go too fast you can have
some
real casualties when it comes to your
parts so
do we think we're ready to run the
program absolutely so then it's just
going to take it out and it's going to
set it over there on the table
yep after it's all done
i always like having my teach pendant
and if we're all good to go
yeah good
even got to see it yeah
so
[Music]
and so what you just saw kick on is
actually an air blast that i'm going to
use for my engraving
along with my chamfer i'm also going to
be utilizing that air blast towards the
end
so it blows any chips around my part off
before i go and pick it up
because that's another thing you don't
want to scar anything on your gripper or
on your part
you like the rapids so far yeah it's
amazing
i like the air i watched the whole
process because i haven't seen the area
nice it actually comes out of both those
nozzles too
and then once it's done engraving you'll
see it do a quick little air blast
around
have you seen it pick it out either that
one's cool
and that's the little and then that's
the air blast making sure there's no
chips around the part
and the robot's about to go back in and
get it
[Music]
think that's good yeah i can stop it
after this part
yeah we'll just let it let us let it
stop
okay
let it take one more out awesome
so uh paul mike you want to come right
back in here
all right jacob you're getting you can
also um be here
so come on in ready to move cameras
squeeze in a little bit yeah you get a
little little bit of distance on it
so anyway great great great application
uh we saw jacob actually grabbed the raw
stock
put it in the vice machined it took it
out and the automation started by
actually going
to the next part and it's continuing
right now
we will have tutorials on our academy
explaining
exactly how to program all of those
moves right there the entire
process and then when we get the
conveyor in
we're going to show with a lot of parts
how to keep it
running just hour after hour and i'm
excited to say we're going to do some
amazing 5-axis work
on this machine also and we're going to
keep switching up the application
and uh making it all happen so thank you
very much
appreciate it great job and great job
brother
great job thank you very much and uh
again i just want to like remind
everybody we got
crazy deals crazy deals 20 20
off but i'm going to shove my mouth now
and bring in my main man dave cox
yes we'll separate all right everybody
out of the way here comes the man
so talking about deals you just heard
the man fanuc
right now 20 off this is all the robo
the select
fanuc robo drill machining center
packages so that includes everything in
there and there's a range you guys so
when you go to the site
and you go to titanthecnc.compromo
you're going to click the fanuc link
and that's going to take you and you're
going to get to see this range of
packages everything from bare bones if
that's what you want
to fully machine fully like set up turn
key ready to go
and remember robots in the robo drill
specifically
this is about freeing up your people to
do
more skilled processes to make sure that
they have the ability
to get in there and they're not just
pushing buttons they're not just moving
apart off
but this helps automate that process and
that's kind of what's lost a lot
we talk about automation people just
think oh it happens automatically
but they're not thinking about what that
operator was doing
to what they're now capable of taking on
as a project so
think about that when you start to think
about how can we integrate the fanuc
robo drill or other automation into our
process
is what are they freed up to now do
rather than standing there waiting for
the machine to finish
all right so that's this promo 20 off
again it's titanscnc.com
promo and titan is going to come back up
right now
we're going to talk about what's coming
up next here we go
oh all right so it's like a marathon
we're just finishing up with our third
episode
our fourth episode will be at 3 p.m
pacific standard time and it's where we
are going to
finish and show the ending of the
machining
on our big mill turn and at that time
we're gonna we're gonna talk about
the part we're gonna talk about the
application we're gonna show
the machining and we're gonna step in
because what happens when you finish
something it's all about the quality
and so we're gonna step into quality
we're gonna go over to
our mitutoyo cmm and we're gonna
actually run a demo and talk about
actually inspecting that part because
the part has to be perfect before you
ship it to the customer right so
anyway at 3 pm we will see you there
thank you very much for
joining the boom bastic show remember
deals deals deals uh check it out
i'm out boom uh what's up everybody this
is titan titans of cnc
and my son tyson hey what's up everyone
oh
so what an incredible day and uh for
those that haven't uh
been with us yet welcome to the boom
bastic
show here at titans of cnc uh we're
excited because we're actually showing
some
really cool machining demos and uh
if you go to the first episode this
morning this being number four
we actually went in through all the
tooling uh we've gone through
programming and uh we've been showing
this part that we're running on the big
old doosan
mill turn and uh making it happen it's
coming out awesome right
yeah it's coming in yep and uh so tyson
is on his second part right now
and what is awesome is that we in this
episode we're going to take a step away
from the machining
and we're going to go over to our
mitchitoya
cmm and we're going to actually talk
about
quality and the importance of not only
perfecting the process on the machine
and and making the program just
absolutely perfect
but actually taking it through the
inspection process so you can actually
keep yourself accountable and make sure
that everything is
absolutely dialed but uh before
tyson maybe you can talk about where
we're at in the process
right now yeah so we're doing some bulk
we're doing some ball tracking on the
part right now
we roughed it out with a 3 8 harvey one
t e end milk sixty thou radius
so now we're opening up the three
eighths uh
slot that we did with the half with a
half inch
harvey three ball mill
so it's just it starts at the top of the
slot works its way down
um kind of light kind of a light cut but
yeah it's been coming out really nice
full five axes so roughing with the
harvey one te
coming back with a duo lock the six
flute
harvey three and uh just coming in with
that ball
end mill and just like coming in and
kissing it for both of these ops these
slots are at an angle
so as it's as it's um as it's being
machined the c-axis is turning along
with the part so it's supply
5-axis motion awesome awesome
and uh after this we're basically
going to be drilling chamfering
and thread milling yep this is the last
last slot we're working on so we'll have
some
pretty m much more exciting ops after
this yeah that's awesome there you go
i'll let him do his thing
so now it'll be should be drilling
we've got this why which drill is this
this is the wi-tech drill from kind of
metal it's a 12 millimeter
awesome so one one thing
important thing to mention is that this
is 6804
d titanium uh this is a titanium that we
actually machine regularly for the
aerospace
industry and uh that therefore we had a
lot of indus
industry experience and we thought hey
you know what let's actually do it on
the middle turn
and then let's actually make tutorials
so
in the future not only will you see a
youtube video
showing all of the machining every
single tool
every surface foot every chip load all
of it
but it will actually also give you the
setup sheets all the instructions
everything
it'll drop on the academy and uh it'll
be awesome
kicking up the feed right now yeah yeah
so what's your what's your surface foot
on this
oh i believe
you know i can't remember the surface
footage i'm sorry um
it's at a thousand rpm right now cool
and then uh
we got a feed rate of three inches per
minute
awesome cool and uh one thing i want to
say is like
you know this is like we are bringing
the
this is the industry right we actually
went to our partners
we said hey our industry has actually
gone going through troubles they've been
locked down
so let's go to our partners and say hey
let's give incredible deals so at this
time i'd like to say
you know kennemado has come out with
some incredible deals
uh mr toyo doosan doosan is at
25 to 30 percent off machines right now
their top 65 models it's an incredible
deal
you can go to titans titansofcnc.com
backslash promo to look at all the deals
for
all of our partners uh titans of cnc my
team we're not taking a cut
at all it's all about giving you guys
the best price so you guys can up
your game and uh give you some education
to
take your skills to another level so
check that out and uh
now all the coolant the synergy 735
coming through that drill
is uh you can see it though yeah
it's awesome sounds like butter right
there like just just going through
nice that's the through hole right now
so awesome
so this time you know we are going to
actually put this
video the entire machining process on
youtube
and again on our academy so i'm going to
say great job to my son tyson thank you
what's up brother doing it live his
first
titanium real meal turn part and we put
the cameras on live right what a dad
all right so at this time i'm gonna sit
i'm gonna head right
over here and we're gonna go to the cmm
and we're gonna talk inspection
gentlemen oh hey
boom i'm catching my camera what's up
mike
jeremy boom how are you guys doing great
today great
that's great that's great so as you guys
can see we have a part on the cmm
and you know one of the cool things is a
lot of people are going to be like wait
titan just walked from the mill turn and
literally went
20 feet over and he's by a cmm
and yes we do have temperature control
but usually you don't see
cmms on a shop floor but that's the
exciting part because this is a new
style of cmm
and it's built for applications where
you have coolant where you have
industrial things going on
and you actually are able to actually
perform in that place right
that's correct and a couple of the the
features of this
are really you know this is a hunk of
iron this is cast iron
so the first thing you have to do is
build for the shop floor so we build for
the shop floor by making good materials
the second thing we do is we build for
temperature compensation so we have real
time temperature compensation
this machine will operate from 10 to 40
c
which for everyone else is 50 degrees to
and that's a really big temperature
range so we don't have to build an air
conditioning unit
saves us money saves us time lets us put
the machine on here we can compensate
not
only the axes but also the part or the
fixture
so we have real control over the machine
okay
the next part of this machine is it's
got to be easy to put down
can we put it wherever we want yeah it's
a single 110 volt
that's it one cord plug in notice
there's no air no sharp air so all those
things make it easy they make it
functional
they make it a sharp floor machine okay
the other part is
really constructed so that you can have
everything compact in one little spot
so not only is it build for the shop
floor it's got to be designed for the
shop floor
so we look at the design and if you look
behind me it's a very open design
okay that means i can put big parts from
this side
i can put long parts from this side and
then
down the road we're going to put a robot
here and we're going to load the parts
from that way because the future is
automation
right absolutely absolutely so lots of
features and functions when we talk
about
build for the shop floor stable easy
flexible
the next part is is design for the shop
floor
make it easy to load easy to work on
okay
but what happens with the cmm it's got
to be accurate
so how accurate is it this is a 2.2
micron machine
86 millions that's pretty darn good
on the screen okay yeah it's got to be
fast
okay this machine moves around at 24
inches a second
so it approaches speeds that machine
tools do
it's just happen to have a measuring
head on it yeah awesome and the last
part is flexibility
what happens when you get a part that's
this complex this is not exactly
you know the little building block from
the over the thing not to
look at that but this is a pretty
complex part so we have
some real high-end technology when we're
talking about the probe head
so that's an indexable probe head it
means it moves around
it also is a scanning probe head now
this
is probably on the higher end of most
regular shops
so we can have a fixed probe head and a
touch trigger one so we
have the gamut here but we also have one
that
we certainly want to show on titan's
behalf of how good this thing can do so
that's awesome and i think it's a great
product in that room
i mean mitch tutorial is the standard in
excellence when it comes to quality
control
and everybody knows that and uh thank
you very much
you know this time i'm just going to say
real quick remember what i said
machining demos wisdom knowledge and
deals deals deals
so one of the cool things is mitch
tutorial on this cmm
and it's a reasonably priced cmm they're
giving up to twelve thousand dollars off
this cmm right here for your shop floor
and they also you have some deals up to
off i believe on our regular tools
on different measuring so you can
actually go down to titansofcnc.com
backslashpromo and you can actually go
down and
look at all the deals for mitchut oil
incredible measurement equipment at
amazing prices
just for you guys and on and check out
all of our other partners
the prices are absolutely amazing again
we're not taking a cut
the deals are for you guys we're doing
it for the trade
and boom so let me actually introduce
you now to my man
travis my quality manager what's up
travis how are you doing brother
oh making it happen right sure man yeah
like i said awesome you can make chips
but if you don't make a part to spec
then what do you got
yeah all those aerospace days all those
light
late nights inspecting making sure we
get parts out
it's all paying off right now right
absolutely absolutely absolutely and
then we have jeremy
over there how are you man thank you
comment thank you so uh maybe you guys
can talk
a little bit about you know the process
like how to program
uh what you guys did the part itself and
actually just
you know tell the viewers a little bit
about what you're gonna do yeah for sure
mike did a great job
jeremy came in we did a little
programming here so let's show you kind
of what the machine can actually do in
action
but it's asleep
perfect timing okay yeah okay so we
wrote a we wrote an inspection program
for this part and what we're going to do
is we're going to run it in steps and
then we're going to talk about the
different
so to make this easy for the operators
the first thing we have is our quick
launcher interface
so instead of file open or anything like
that the operator just walks up picks
this part
it's a touch screen so travis you think
you can and so i like this i i can't
mess this up right it's have to match
the picture of the part right
so picture new part
sure to execute yes all right find out
if i did it right
exactly so this launches our repeat mode
which runs our program
um so it's going to go through set our
cnc parameters load our coordinate
system and now it comes up and says okay
since we have a repeatable fixture we
don't need to do a manual alignment
so we're going to do a cnc alignment
it's waiting on us so go ahead and hit
okay and so i like this it gives
it can give the operator instructions
along the way exactly right
so really the machine's doing all the
work so
what we're going to do is an alignment
uh we're taking a four-point plane on
the top
to square everything up as soon as this
is done
yes sir as soon as this is done we're
going to take a circle around the
outside diameter
so this will align the origin
now as mike said this is an indexable
probe head so we're going to index to
get to the side
for clearance and then we're going to
measure along the edge of one of the
hexes and this will clock the part
so we've done a base paint for uh to
square it up
circle for origin and clock the part
nice and so now it moves out of the way
and
go ahead and stop so now as mike said
before this is a scanning probe an sb25
so this is a constant contact scanning
probe um now we're going to scan
the contour of the top edge so go ahead
and hit okay there this really gives us
quite a few points
around that profile absolutely instead
of just taking four points on a circle
or six points on a circle
we're going to measure a little shy of
300 points as we go around
so it's actually following a tool path
from the cad model
that we've sectioned out and we can see
the points up here right
yes sir so it's measuring perpendicular
to the tangent of each of those points
from the cad model it knows how it's
measured it's just chasing the part
so we can see it plotting the points it
looks like a white line it's really a
bunch of points all close together
as soon as it finishes it'll come up to
a cleaner tight
approaching 300 points yep 288 290 i
think it finished that
okay so now it's measured that contour
we can compare that to the cad model
yeah or we could cut that into
individual circles
and do geometry on it okay so uh when
you're ready we'll go ahead and start on
the hex
okay ready to measure hex let's do it so
once again with that indexable probe
head
we're gonna index so that we're
perpendicular to the face
so i've got some clearance moves in
there so we don't smack the part
the probe is actually at 150 degrees
which is perpendicular to that hex
okay so we're going to get good true
measurements now
i'm doing a scan around the perimeter
that's called a gasket
scan and now i'm going to go in and
measure the circle now it's a threaded
hole
so i'm chasing the threads out
incrementally so you're following that
pitch kind of as you come out
if you don't then you'll be shifted into
the minor diameter yeah so by
by chasing the threads it stays true
once again gas gets scanned around the
outside
and i got this information from the cad
model
and then go in and chase this one we're
chasing inside on this one
[Music]
okay so now these were prismatic
measurements planes circles things like
that
easy measurements right easy step right
uh now we're going to measure the flutes
so the flutes are i mean you have the
ball end mill go in there and you're
twisting around as you're moving out
it's a complex measurement but we don't
want complex results we want simple
results is it deep enough
or is my angle correct so what we're
going to do is we section this in three
different spots
and we're going to measure a scan at
three different heights so if you go
ahead and hit okay yep
she's going to measure the first one so
from the cad model i defined a path
and it comes in makes contact and then
now it's going to start scanning
just a section of the flute i can't go
all the way around
because i'll shank out yeah now i'm
going to go up i've got the same probe
position because
i've got a big fat 5 millimeter probe on
there
and that way i won't shank out so it
should be good
now you're checking it in three
different spots so that'll allow sort of
to see if that path deviated a little
bit i know that part's sticking out of
the chuck right there right so you might
see if it started to flex or if you
start to get deflection at the top
right exactly so when you first come in
to make contact everything's good and
rigid
and then as you move further out to the
free end of the part
it might flex on you so that would be
good information to then take
share with your machinist let him know
that he might want to alter his setup or
adjust his tool path
to make it accurate exactly absolutely
so the inspection finishes
now comes up and it's kind of hard to
see from that distance but there's a
little green okay in the top corner
which means that the part has finished
and it is acceptable and either would
print the results or send it up to your
statistical collection software whatever
you're using so if we if we want to know
that's good we're okay but let's say i
was chasing a true position i knew i
kind of had to shift it a little bit or
something
we can go ahead and have results print
out that lets us know exactly where that
is
exactly and we can actually program it
so that if everything's good it doesn't
print out anything yeah okay and if
something's bad it will print out the
bad features
nice so instead of looking at a 300
feature report
you're looking at the two things that
were bad makes it a lot easier and then
if nothing is on the report it'll say
all good
you take that you're good to go all the
data's in the in your database
nice so a lot of versatility right from
the basic all the way up to the complex
3d
absolutely nice
what's up man great job great job thank
you oh
wasn't that awesome so uh
the part is complete and uh again on
this specific part right here
made out of 604b titanium we're going to
make our youtube video
we'll show the entire application giving
every single kenmetal tool
every surface foot every chip load we're
gonna make it happen
and uh that will be coming soon uh one
of the exciting things is tomorrow
we're gonna actually be on our five axis
right here
and uh we got an amazing part on the dvf
6500 stuart's working on
like he was here till like midnight last
night he's working on it right now and
uh all the pressures on him because uh
tomorrow
lights camera action 9 a.m we're gonna
make it happen
and uh at the end of the day we're gonna
have it over here and we're gonna be
working on some inspection like how do
you actually inspect
this complicated five axis part and uh
it's gonna be amazing so
thank you very much uh looking forward
to tomorrow it's going to be amazing
and uh before we go we're going to bring
in mr dave cox and he's going to talk to
you guys about
all the deals deals deals
boom all right guys you know what time
it is it's time to save some money
let's do it we've already heard stories
today about people saving thousands and
thousands of dollars
by taking these deals into account and
actually jumping on these promos so
what i want to talk to you about right
now is mitchutoyo since i'm standing in
front of the machine
this thing right here the 555 my star
is up to 12 000 off
up to 12 000 off that's insane that's
like a a gently used kia
that's 12 000 tacos on taco tuesday you
know i like taco tuesday
so 12 grand off that's insane that's the
thing you want to go ahead and get for
your shop floor so you can just go from
machine straight to inspection and get
back to machining so
12 000 off on that 30 up to 35 percent
off on their precision tools
that's all your calipers that's height
gauges that's everything that they have
in that list and the way you want to get
that deal is go to tightens the cnc.com
promo all right that's the last time i
tell you about it today so you better go
quick
the other thing i want to remind you
about is doosan that 25 to 30
off is no joke that's insane again
titans for doosan.com is where you're
going to find those deals
you sign up they send you the link
everything's taken care of
and that's off 65 of their different
models right so that's
horizontal mills vertical mills lathes
all that kind of stuff
the other thing you need to remember is
they have that gerstner giveaway
okay so there's two ways to get your
free gerstner one
just buy a machine super simple pull out
the checkbook pull out the credit card
get those airline miles and get a
machine get your gerstner okay just do
that
second is you go ahead and sign up at
the site and you're gonna be entered to
win
our gerstner that we have here on site
that's a killer deal next up let's talk
about canna metal all right let's remind
you guys
that those end mills are on sale the 3 8
for 41
the half inch for 56 dollars that's your
harvey threes
your harvey one tes your core five and a
dollar from every end mill
goes to the wounded warrior project to
help our veterans all right
so remember that that's a killer deal
right there with blaser
we want to remind you guys about the lta
package that's the
liquid tool analysis that's a free
liquid tool analysis
and when you do that they have 20
percent off
off of their liquids their coolants
their cutting oils grinding oils all
that kind of stuff for your initial fill
and 20 off for accessories and cleaners
so don't forget that one don't pass it
up
that's going to be at blazer.com boom
bastic that's a little bit of a
different length than the other ones
blaster.com
slash boombastic let's revisit shank for
a second so shunk has their 20
off for the vero s and the contact
packages and the thw plus chuck remember
that's 20 percent off
and remember mike gaunts came back in
and he was like hey dave
you got to tell them we're going to do
the impact series claw jaws
and if there's anything that they don't
like about them they can send them right
back so that's unconditional
guarantee i believe it's 30 days so just
try them get them and then send them
back
that's it titanscnc.com promo
you guys warm because i'm warm all right
next
up tms titanium remember these guys are
helping us out
give you guys education they're giving
us the amazing material that we use to
teach on
and that tms titanium deal is a free
swag bag when you order with them so
it's just
store.tmstitanium.com and then use the
code boombastic in the order notes
they're going to give you a pretty
insane swag bag that's awesome
mastercam's doing 20 off all right so
that's all their mastercam core products
titanscnc.com again slash promo and that
includes their mill lathe router design
wire mill turn and master cam for
solidworks that's a killer deal
bannock we talked about the robo drill
already don't forget
20 20 off a robo drill that's lights out
automation that's the whole thing
set up any package you want that's from
bare bones all the way to insane mode
20 off you just got to go to the site
again titanscnc.com
promo scroll down to fanuc hit that
button and it's going to take you right
to see all of those different packages
you can have cool
all right and
that's it for those promos but next up
tomorrow
when we kick things off here's what we
need you to do we need you guys to all
be on there watching again because we're
going to kick things off
with an absolute giveaway perfectly free
giveaway
in the first episode tomorrow so that's
happening
and hymer is also tomorrow
that's coming up now you guys hymer came
in i mean i don't know if i can even
tell you about this but
it's insane what you're going to see i
mean this just trust me you're going to
want to see this hymer
set up that we have all the i mean it's
just crazy
so come back and visit us tomorrow tell
your friends we're going to do a
giveaway
and that's it for today thanks for
enjoying us with
all four episodes today we will see you
tomorrow
you